wie schnell kann sich die restaurant und
gastronomiebranche von dieser krise
erholen darüber möchten wir jetzt
sprechen mit holger beeck dem chef von
mcdonald's hier in deutschland gut
namens herbig schön dass sie hier bei
uns sind ja wir haben gerade schon
darüber gesprochen natürlich wird vor
allem die gastrobranche jetzt sehr stark
davon betroffen
die restaurants müssen zu bleiben das
noch eine ganze weile werden jetzt von
bayerns ministerpräsident markus söder
im juni soll es frühestens weitergehen
was bedeutet das also für ihre ganze
branche erst mal guten tag und dann
zunächst einmal sechs wochen weitere
schließung bedeutet das und ich glaube
dass ein arbeitsplatzabbau
die folge sein könnte und zwar weil es
insolventen im größeren stil geben wird
viele setzen jetzt natürlich auf das
angebot dass man außer haus essen
mitnehmen kann oder auf lieferdienste
wie viel hilft das tatsächlich bei den
umsatzausfällen die jetzt gerade
natürlich stattfinden also das hilft
natürlich aber in einem kleineren rahmen
auch bei uns bei mcdonald's ich habe
umsatzsteigerung von 100% im liefer
segment aber dieses segment ist relativ
klein weil in deutschland oft die
infrastruktur fehlt und die geografie
erlaubt es auch nicht dass im größeren
stil zu machen jetzt noch nicht die
unternehmen ist vor allem auch an
plätzen beliebt wo es ums reisen geht
bahnhöfe flughäfen raststätten all diese
sind jetzt besonders wenig natürlich
besucher reisen gerade keine möglichkeit
ist was genau bedeutet das für
mcdonald's das bedeutet dass viele
restaurants geschlossen sind an
autobahnen weil kein auto da ist ein
flughäfen weil keine flugzeuge starten
passagierzahlen sich
in den 1955 das letzte mal in seinem
bereich befinden und an den bahnhöfen
ist die frequenz extrem gering
also das betreiben von restaurants dort
macht im moment aus meiner sicht keinen
sinn
können sie uns etwas über den konkreten
wirtschaftlichen schaden der korona
krise bei mcdonald sagen der ist auf
jeden fall groß und natürlich messbar
sie wissen mcdonald's die restaurants
werden zu 95 prozent von selbstständigen
mittelständischen unternehmern geführt
und die sind genauso betroffen wie jeder
andere in der in der industrie wir haben
das glück dass wir mit unserem drive
restaurants ja nahezu kontaktlos nach
außen verkaufen dürfen und können
das lindert den schaden aber der schaden
ist hoch
die politik stellt jetzt verschiedene
hilfsangebote in aussicht dabei
mehrwertsteuersenkungen
überbrückungskredite all das wie hier
würde dass tatsächlich helfen
na gut wenn sie ihn betrogen sinn oder
wirklich unter druck sind dann hilft
natürlich einen kredit aber der muss
zurückgezahlt werden
ich plädiere deshalb dafür maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um die unternehmer auch in die
lage zu versetzen ihre schulden
auszugleichen und deswegen brauchen wir
in der gastronomie eine
mehrwertsteuersenkung auf 7 prozent und
das aus meiner sicht fünf jahre lang und
danach gegen uns unterhalten ob ihr
schrittweise wieder erhöhen forderung
also aus der gastronomie vielen dank
herr weg dass sie heute abend hier bei
uns waren und ihre einschätzung zu der
situation gegeben haben